(hairdryer running)
- Oh, I'm sorry, were you sleeping?
(upbeat music)
- Oh, I can clean that up if you want.
- Let's order food.
- Sure, can we get something
cheap, though, like Chinese?
- Not a fan.
Pizza?
- I'm lactose intolerant.
- June, let's go out tonight.
- No, I was just gonna stay
in and get some work done, so.
- Ugh, fine, I guess I'll do that too.
So boring, oh.
- Burgers?
- I don't eat red meat.
Italian?
- Pasta doesn't agree with me.
(upbeat music)
- Don't worry, my roommate's sleeping.
- Go to sleep, go to sleep, go to sleep,
go to sleep, go to sleep.
- Tacos?
- Dude, I just had tacos last night.
Indian food?
- Nah.
- [Tiffany] Hey, girl.
- Hey.
Did you take money from me?
- Oh, yeah, I borrowed
20 dollars from you,
but I'll pay you back later.
- So she fucks a guy
while you're in the room,
and the borrowed money is the final straw?
- Dude, stolen money, man.
Do you know how poor I am?
Very, very poor.
- Okay, this is due back soonish.
- I just, I don't know
how much more I can take.
- [Woman] Madison, take 15.
- Outside, outside?
- Yes, let's do it.
- Dude, she just like, she
tries to go with me everywhere.
Like, I had to leave while
she was in the bathroom
just to get here.
- Oh, have you tried talking to her?
- I have tried.
You're not there, you're
not in the trenches with me.
Do you know when the last
time I masturbated was?
Four months ago, because
she's always there.
I should move out.
- I don't know.
If it were me, I would just,
at least try talking to her,
because, dude, moving
is just like the worst.
- The worst.
- Yeah, it sucks.
- I mean, I guess I can try to talk to her
and be like an adult or whatever.
- Yeah, give it a shot.
Are you gonna go now?
- Go where?
- You're high.
(laughter)
- Oops.
(gentle music)
- Tiffany, we need to talk.
- Yes, June, we do.
I'm sorry to say, but I'm moving out.
- What?
(upbeat music)